ici il n'ya pas de terroristes le
premier terroriste y aura sera au
premier étage juste au dessus une prise
d'otage par plusieurs terroristes voilà
le scénario principal de cet exercice
pour les unités du raid première phase
la préparation et la mise en place des
éléments par l'équipe de formation
certains vont jouer le rôle des
terroristes avec des consignes pour se
rapprocher au plus près des situations
réelles
le but c'est que la protection c'est
l'otage
élie desbin t2 d'engager le feu sur les
forces de l'ordre
quand tu vois qu'ils arrivent tu te
prépare psychologiquement et tu viens
sur eux ici tout en engageant boum boum
boum boum boum éventuellement pendant ta
course eu peu la feta deuxième grenade
et tu viens sur eux en qu'amicale c'est
de la façon de procéder de de ces gens
là donc autant faire en exercice pour
les préparer au but pendant quatre
semaines chaque mercredi le raid dispose
de ce bâtiment propriété de la société i
nîmes antenne cfc développement il va
être détruit
le groupement d'intervention spécialisés
de la police nationale peut s'exercer
dans des conditions optimales ce site
pour nous aider grande importance parce
que parce qu'on peut sans on peut aussi
entraîner dans des conditions qui nous
rapproche de la réalité
l'eau qui peuvent soit utilisées un
calibre 12 soit éventuellement une micro
charge explosive puisqu'ils vont
considérer que la porte est fermée à clé
si je vois qu'un opérateur se met en
danger et qui pays qui présentent des
blessures et ben je peux sortir une
fiche et l'accrocher à l'individu et lui
demander de se mettre au sol dans cet
exercice 25 opérateurs du raid divisés
en deux équipes d'aso vont participer
tout le monde est en place
l'entraînement peut commencer
[Applaudissements]
créé en 1985 le raid est rattachée au
ministère de l'intérieur résolution de
prise d'otage arrestation d'individus
dangereux protection de personnalités
les unités interviennent sur ce type de
situation les entraînements sont
hebdomadaires
on va avoir affaire à des gens qui vont
être très déterminé en phase avec un
risque de mort ils ont des explosifs
ils ont des armes à feu la moindre
petite erreur pour nous de placement
peut entraîner des blessures ou la mort
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes s'entraînent très régulièrement
ils répètent des schémas tactiques
constamment pour être le plus efficace
possible
lors d'une crise le raid est implanté
dans dix sites en france métropolitaine
et trois bases dans les outre-mers 450
personnes sont engagées dans ce
groupement d'intervention spécialisés de
la police nationale